[THEME MUSIC]
JOSH WOODWARD: All right.
Hi, everyone.
Thank you for coming.
My name is Josh, and
I'm a product manager
on the Next Billion
Users team at Google.
And we're really
glad you're here.
We want to basically
use this session
to tell you a little bit about
what we've been learning,
building for the next billion
in places like India, Indonesia,
Brazil, and other
countries around the world.
Before we get started,
just maybe a show of hands,
who's flown in
from India for I/O?
Oh, awesome.
I know it's very late
right now for you all,
so we'll try to keep you up.
Anybody from
Indonesia who's here?
OK, a couple, cool.
Brazil?
Great.
And I'm sure there's a lot of
other countries represented
too.
So thank you all for coming.
What I wanted to do just
quickly by way of intro,
before we interview some
of the folks on stage,
is tell you a
little bit about how
this initiative and this focus
area for Google got started.
Since the beginning,
Google has always
been interested in building
products for everyone.
And what we realized,
looking around the world,
is literally a
billion new people
come online for the first time.
That changes how we think
about some of the ways
we develop products.
And really, this
session, we want
to share some of those
lessons with you.
Some of the things we've got
right, some of the things
we got wrong, too.
One thing that's changed is
how we think about our existing
products.
If you think about YouTube,
or Search, or Maps, or Chrome,
or any of the others.
What we found is
a whole new crop
of user behaviors that are
becoming really common in
[INAUDIBLE].
For example, today in India,
28% of the searches we see
are voice searches,
which is amazing.
And it's growing, voice
is growing everywhere
around the world.
Brings up really
interesting questions
about how you interact
with computing devices,
localization, and others.
We've also seen in Google
Maps, for example, our new Two
Wheeler mode feature.
Really popular, and spreading
to other markets too.
There's new modalities
we're having to solve
for transportation directions.
That's a little bit about
how we've started thinking
about our existing products.
But obviously, as smartphone
prices drop around the world,
as connectivity becomes
more affordable,
more people come online, and
it opens up brand new use cases
and problems to solve.
And that's really what our
three panelists up here have
been doing the last few years.
So they're going to talk to
you a little bit about some
of the products we've
launched over the last six
to eight months, and a lot of
what's kind of gone into them,
both from the engineering
side as well as the design
and research side.
So what I'll do is just
introduce them briefly,
and then we'll get into
some of the questions.
And at the very end, we've
got two mics in the room.
If people want to come up,
we'll save some time at the end,
you can ask a few questions.
So first, just quick
intros down the row.
I want to introduce
[? Pankesh. ?] [? Pankesh ?]
leads engineering
for Google Tez.
Tez is our payments app in
India that we launched back
in September.
And there's a whole
lot of stories
he can share about that
in just a few minutes.
Up next, we have [? Davesh. ?]
[? Davesh ?] leads our Files Go
engineering team.
Files Go is an app we
launched late last year, that
helps users free up
space on their phone,
find files really fast,
and also share files
offline when you're
nearby people.
So some very
interesting engineering
that went into that product.
And then finally, we have
[? Nithya. ?] [? Nithya ?] is
on our research and design team.
And she's worked on I think,
every product at this point
in some form or fashion.
She's going to share
a lot of lessons
we've learned doing
research, both in the field,
but also we have a
lot of local teams
based around the
world that build
a lot of these products for us.
Our kind of group, the
Next Billion Users group,
really thinks about how do we
staff people in these markets
so we can really watch these
trends as they're emerging.
We also give a lot
of these small teams
a lot of latitude to go
after big repeating problems.
We're an experimental group
trying out a lot of new things.
And of course, the three of
them will talk about some
of the products we've launched.
Without further ado, let's
start with [? Pankesh. ?]
[? Pankesh, ?] maybe just give
us an overview of what Tez is,
and we'll start there.
[? PANKESH: ?] Yes, sure.
Tez is mobile payments
app for India.
And the word Tez
itself means fast
in Hindi and some other
regional languages.
It's built on top of a new
inter-banking protocol.
It's a real-time protocol
that was introduced
in India called up UPI.
That stands for Universal
Payments Interface.
And almost all Indian banks
have implemented this.
It's 24/7, instant bank-to-bank
money transfer protocol.
And what Tez does is it puts
a brand-new, very fresh user
experience on a variety
of payment use cases,
on top of this protocol.
So a Tez user links
their bank account
with their Google account,
and UPI gives them
a payment address, which
is called a virtual payment
address.
Per the protocol, this payment
address is inter-operable,
so any service or
product that is using UPI
has to support this destination
addressing mechanism.
And the neat thing is
that any payments that
are done from this address
or into this address
are done from the bank account,
or into the bank account
directly.
It's different than
a digital wallet.
And you don't have to load
up a digital wallet first
from your bank account, and
then transact from that wallet.
The other neat thing is
that the council, which
maintains and runs
this protocol,
has made these
transactions free of cost.
There's a big push by the
government towards digitization
of payments.
And so effectively, what
you have is instant,
24/7, free, kind of
like a wiring ability.
Literally at your fingertips
on your smartphone.
Why don't I show a demo
of some of these features?
OK.
Well, we were having some Wi-Fi
issues earlier, as they usually
do with the demo.
I have two phones here, if
I could get the volt vision.
OK.
So this volt vision
one is my phone,
and I'm going to get into Tez.
It uses the OS lock,
so we will get here.
I'll do the same on--
sorry about the orientation--
we will do this also on
the phone on the left here.
I will launch the Tez app--
again, use the OS
lock to open it.
And now, we have
these two phones.
And what you see right up
front is a circular button.
And let me explain this.
We call these cash
more payments.
So imagine that a
user has this phone,
and they walk into a shop.
And there's a merchant
behind the counter
who has their own phone.
And so basically, two
phones are nearby--
and one of my phones is working
on India international roaming,
so I hope that it works.
But basically-- let's put
this into the receive mode,
and let's put it
into the pay mode,
and see if the phone
discovers the other phone.
So what should happen--
if WiFi was working--
was that one phone would be
discovered by the other phone.
Let's see.
Boom.
So as you can see,
the phone on the left
has discovered the phone on
the right, which is my phone.
So the user can tap to pay.
And let's say I'm
buying some chai, which
costs a lot these days.
I can put in a message,
I can proceed to pay.
UPI mandates that
every transaction
is protected by a PIN.
And for purposes of this demo
it will go through the bank's--
the destination and the
receiver bank, and voila.
And we're trying something
out when you get this.
So that's how these
nearby payments work.
What you can also see now, just
focusing on the Chromecast,
the phone on the left.
You see these chat heads.
And essentially, these
are profile pictures
of the payment peers.
I can tap on someone--
let's say, this person--
and it will give me the
entire history of the payment
transactions that have happened
between me and this person.
So that's really convenient.
Now if you go down
further, you see
a section called Businesses.
And that has providers,
like my phone provider,
my internet provider.
And we recently integrated bill
payments on top of UPI as well.
So every month, I
get a notification
that hey, your bill is due.
I tap it and it's
done in an instant.
Likewise, you can check balance
and other such things as well.
So that's kind of like a
quick overview of the app.
JOSH WOODWARD: Nice.
[? Pankesh, ?] can you tell
everyone a little bit more
about the cash mode, and
how you guys built that?
A little bit of the
back story there?
[? PANKESH: ?] So it started
with some user insights.
And the key user insight
comes from the fact
that paying by cash is still
quite widespread in India
and other [? MBU ?] markets.
And you know if you think
about it, paying by cash
has its benefits.
It's like pseudo
private, anonymous,
and it's just plain convenient.
So when we wanted to do a
digital mode of payment,
we want it to have an
experience which is kind
of like cash in many senses.
That's why we call it cash mode.
And how it works is--
actually, there are
various ways to make
these nearby or
proximity payments work.
And like in the US, and various
parts of the world, generally
NFC has been the way to go.
But phones in India, most
of them don't have NFC.
So now you can use Wi-Fi, you
can use Bluetooth for pairing.
Essentially, you're trying to
make two phones who have never
seen each other ever, don't
want to exchange explicitly
some addressing information,
to be connected to each other.
So what we do is we
transmit information
for pairing on audio.
Actually using ultrasound.
Let me go into a
little bit more detail.
What happens is, one
phone sends a short ID.
It broadcasts a short ID,
identifying itself saying hey,
this is me, this is me.
And this idea is
broadcast using what's
called DSSS, or Direct
Sequence Spread Spectrum.
And it's a spread
spectrum technique.
What it is doing is it's
multiplying the data signal
by pseudo random noise
spreading signal.
And so what actually
happens is that on audio,
on an inaudible frequency--
nobody can hear it from a user
experience point of view,
that's very important--
what's been transported
is white noise
because of this pseudo
random noise spreading.
And it's very
important for security
because then a snooper can
get access to the signal,
but not make sense out of it.
However, the receiver
can use the same--
and multiply with
the signal that it
gets-- with the same
pseudo random noise code,
and recover the signal.
So the receiver recovers
the ID, validates the ID,
and then does a sober look
up to figure it out, OK,
who does this ID belong to?
And the server sends
back more information,
which is relayed to
the receiving phone.
Just like the other
phone got, OK, you're
paying to [? Pankesh, ?]
and so tap.
That's the user confirmation.
So that's how it works.
I think it's been great
for us as you can imagine,
that there's lots of challenges
in making this work in terms
of tuning and configurations.
There's receiver configuration,
broadcaster configuration,
there's various audio settings.
To kind of give you some
statistics about this,
when we launched-- and Tez
launched in India in September
last year--
we tested about 200 devices
and hand-tuned them in our lab.
And since then, we have
evolved this process of tuning,
and now it's a control
system, like feedback loop,
in which we just
adjust automatically
the parameters in the field.
And observe how that goes.
And to date, we have
nearly 6,000 unique devices
who have made a
successful cash mode
transaction, of which manually,
we only configured 200.
So I think it was
extremely important to us
that we get the coverage that
we eventually ended up getting.
And that's why we chose
audio, over say, NFC.
JOSH WOODWARD:
Interesting, nice.
Maybe one last question for you.
Briefly, can you
share a little bit
about what you've
learned working
with a new app, a new
protocol, and UPI,
a lot of external partners?
And I think there's a
war story here, maybe?
PANKESH: This protocol is very
new, and a lot of the banks--
and we have the largest banks
in India as our partners,
and they were implementing
it new as well.
So we literally broke
the bank when we
launched, with such a high QPS.
But you know, when you're
building any distributed
system, whether
it's your components
or external
components, then you've
got some health monitoring
and various other kind
of high availability things.
So what we do is a
couple of things,
just to give a
quick example each.
User account creation time, when
this address has been created--
if one bank is down, then we
will go to the other bank.
At the payment time,
however, you're
transferring from one Bank A
to Bank B. And what's important
is to not have the user in
what's called a stuck state.
For that what we do is we build
ML predictive models to figure
out whether any of the
banks-- there's actually
five parties in a transaction,
the way the protocol defines
it-- and any of them, if
it is down, or almost done,
then we would rather bring
it up with the user, and say,
hey, please try again.
Rather than having the
risk of the transaction
kind of entering in a little bit
of a stuck state, where nobody
knows where the money has gone.
JOSH WOODWARD: Nice.
Great.
Thank you for sharing.
[? Davesh, ?] I want to
shift gears a little bit
and talk about Files Go.
And maybe you can tell us
just briefly what it is.
I think you'll want to
show us about it too.
[? DAVESH: ?] Files Go is a
file and storage management app
built for [? MBU ?] markets
for mobile first users.
It also supports
peer-to-peer sharing
using nearby technology.
It doesn't use the internet.
The way it all
started, we started
looking at what the users
in [? MBU ?] markets needed.
And we realized first off that
mobile data in these markets
were very expensive.
And what that meant was,
users in these markets
were not able to consume
content on their phones, which
was a primary or
only device for them.
Most of the time
because of the expense.
That's where the idea for
nearby sharing was born.
Then as we were
researching more,
we realized that
once users got access
to more content which they
could get from their friends,
a lot of these phones have
very little internal storage.
So users started
running out of storage
when they got content
from their friends.
Because of that, we started
looking at storage management.
The other problem
that we saw was
users were not able to find
the content on their phone
easily, because most
of the existing file
managers out there show a
folder [INAUDIBLE] view, which
is complicated for new
users who are coming
to the mobile first time, have
never used a laptop or desktop
computer before.
So we decided to build
something that would be easy
for them to use, would
allow them to keep
their phones clean, and
allow them to get content
from their friends.
JOSH WOODWARD: Cool.
You want to show it?
[? DAVESH: ?] Let me show it.
JOSH WOODWARD: One thing while
he's pulling up the demo--
I remember when this team
came back from field research.
They spent a lot of time on
college campuses across India.
And we found a stat
which was shocking--
one out of three
smartphone users in India
run out of storage, or see a
low storage warning, every day.
So if you think
about that, something
like 80 million people
are constantly up
against the boundary of
running out of storage.
Anyway, we'll switch
over to the Wolf Vision
and you can show how it works.
[? DAVESH: ?] Is the
phone showing up?
JOSH WOODWARD: Yup.
[? DAVESH: ?] So this
is a Files Go app.
First stop, right
on top, we show
the storage available
on the phone
and what's the total storage.
The cards that you see here
are personalized additions
for the users on what they
can clean up from the phone,
to free up storage.
Let's go and take a look
at the large files card.
These are all the large
files on the phone.
Typically these are
videos that users shoot,
or the kind they get from their
friends, like movies and stuff.
So with one click
delete, you can just
get it off this user card
back to 180 MB of data.
Let's take a look at files.
So one thing that
we saw was users
had a tough time trying to find
the content on their phone.
We came up with the scheme of
categorizing the content based
on how it was acquired or how it
was associated in users' minds.
For example, images.
We don't show a folder view.
You can see all images here,
and then the other tabs
show where the users think
the images came from.
Similarly for videos.
Again, it's
categorized in groups
that users can identify with.
Right down here, you see two
buttons for send and receive.
This is where users can
initiate the nearby sharing
mode to transfer content
to or from their friends.
Interesting thing-- just like
[? Pankesh ?] talked about,
doing a nearby connection
sounds simplistic enough,
but there's a bunch of
stuff involved there.
Because there's a
wide variety of phones
out there in the market.
We use a combination of
Bluetooth, Bluetooth Low
Energy, Wi-Fi direct, Wi-Fi
hotspot type of technologies.
And based on the
two phones, we are
able to connect on Bluetooth and
negotiate their capabilities,
and create the fastest
connection possible.
For example, if the two phones
both support 5 GHz band,
then we can connect
on 5 GHz, which
will result in a file
transfer rate of a GB
around 40 seconds, which
is pretty impressive.
Which wouldn't have
happened if we'd
gone on the path of
just using Wi-Fi, which
is sort of the default path.
The other thing that
I wanted to talk about
was the low-resolution
and memes.
So one thing that we
noticed in our user research
again was that users
in these markets
used chat apps quite a bit, and
they receive a ton of content
from their friends.
Most of which is good morning
messages, memes, jokes,
which they don't want to
really keep because it fills up
their phone.
At the same time,
they also receive
content from their friends
which they want to keep,
which might be pictures of each
other that they took on a trip
together.
Which meant users were going
through going through all
these chat messages and
deleting stuff manually
by figuring out what was
useful and what was not.
We decided to try
to tackle this,
and we came up with
this card that--
internally we use Google
Vision API, Vision Library,
to do text detection.
And then add heuristics to that
to detect memes or images that
are not useful for the user
which they view only once.
And these are some of the
things that get detected.
And the user can use one
click again to delete it,
and they can keep the rest of
their useful messages in tact
without having to go
through it manually.
JOSH WOODWARD: Cool.
One thing also-- just
to call out from this
that the team has seeing--
is that the average user,
the first time they use
the app, is freeing up
over a gig of storage.
And so that little bubble
boy is dancing a lot when
storage space is freeing up.
It's become a really
interesting daily
and weekly habit
people have gone into.
Maybe one last question for you,
[? Davesh, ?] before we move
on [? to Nithya. ?] Can you tell
us a little bit about what you
feel like you've learned so far?
This app has only been
out about four months.
It launched at the
end of last year.
[? DAVESH: ?] There's a
bunch of stuff we learned.
The most interesting
for me was the fact
that this app is getting used
a whole lot in US and Europe,
which we did not expect
when we launched it.
I recently read a book
by Vijay Govindarajan
called "Reverse
Innovation," which
talks a lot about building
products specifically
for these markets,
which you can then
bring back and [INAUDIBLE]
other markets which you did not
build the product for.
And we are seeing
something similar
for Files Go, which
is very fulfilling.
JOSH WOODWARD: Nice.
I guess, Nithya, you
can take us home here
with the last set of
questions, before we open it up
to everyone.
Talk to us a little bit about
some of the thematic work
you've done, around
connectivity and access
with your sort of research
and design experience.
[? NITHYA: ?] So
as part of Google's
mission of bringing the benefits
of the internet to everyone,
there are two main products.
There's Google Station, which
provides high quality internet
access in the form of
public Wi-Fi and Datally,
which is a mobile application,
which helps users get
more value out of their data.
So I'll talk about
Station first.
Station was launched in 2016,
and is now in India, Indonesia,
and Mexico, in
hundreds of hotspots
like train stations, parks,
malls, and public venues.
Thousands of users, people
come online for the first time
on the station network.
Datally really helps make the
existing constrained internet
more manageable and accessible.
So it provides
data transparency,
so that users can
understand where
their MBs and GBs are going
in their browsing activities.
It provides data
saving functionality,
which helps users get more
value, extend their data packs.
And it also alerts users
to public Wi-Fi hotspots
when they're outside, so users
can be online more often.
And the underlying
insight for Datally
is that many people
around the world
treat mobile data as money.
Because it is expensive,
slow, and limited.
And as a result, users
resort to practices
like turning off mobile
data when they're not
using it to cut costs.
Or hesitate to get
new applications,
or have fears around using
existing applications.
So that limits their
participation online.
And Datally provides
functionality to help
users ease into their
experience of getting
more value from the internet.
JOSH WOODWARD: Can
you talk a little bit
about what we've learned
with these products,
now that they've been out,
and sort of the environment
that they've landed in?
[? PANKESH: ?] I can go
on for long about this,
but to simplify things--
there's people,
context, and devices.
So with regards to people,
as internet access is
growing all over the
world, technology
is touching new societies.
And a lot of the people
that are coming online
are increasingly diverse.
So there's diverse literacies,
languages, aspirations,
income levels, professions,
geographic spread.
And many of the
assumptions that we've
made around the first few
billion users need rethinking.
So for example, it
may not hold true
that users are well educated,
or relatively wealthy,
or English-speaking, even.
Many people around
the next billion users
are not necessarily
English-speaking primarily,
but may prefer to use phone
UIs in English, because English
is seen as a language of
upward mobility and aspiration.
So in terms of
design, how might we
design interfaces
that help users
with the use of simplified
English and more visually rich
interfaces.
With regards to context,
like I mentioned,
internet is often
intermittent and constrained.
Roughly only 43% of the
world has access to LTE.
So users are often on 2G and
3G, and sometimes even offline.
So how do we think
about designing
for these constrained networks?
And treating offline as not an
error case, but as a normative
use case.
We also have to think
about economic factors,
like purchasing power, and,
like [? Pankesh ?] mentioned,
the prevalence of cash, and
social factors like gender
and the role of religion
in using technology.
And then finally with
regards to devices.
Today, you can buy an
Android phone for $30 to $40.
It is very likely to have
a small screen, low RAM,
low processing power, but it
is the first computing device
that many people have access to.
And many of these
devices don't get
replaced as often as they
might here in the West,
because of cultures of
frugality and gift giving.
So how might we think about
hardware and software design
for low-end devices?
JOSH WOODWARD: Maybe
one last question,
because I'm sure we've
got a range of folks
from different backgrounds here.
But on sort of
wearing your UX hat,
if you had to pass
along some research
and design tips
and tricks you've
learned along the way
over the last few years,
what would you
share with everyone?
[? NITHYA: ?] First I'll
alert you to our collection
of research and design
methods on design.google/nbu.
You can find it--
it's part of the
Google Design web site.
And we regularly share new
design and research methods,
as well as product stories,
in the behind the scenes look.
With regards to research
and design innovations,
I'll talk about it through the
lens of a product lifecycle.
When we start to
build a product,
and we're trying to
understand the problem space,
and we want to create a
vision for the product--
we really want a
foundation of rich insights
and understanding of
people and the relationship
with technology and
the unmet needs.
So here we've introduced
techniques like intercepts,
and the more traditional
ethnographic immersion.
Intercepts are spot
interviews that
are done with people
in various contexts,
such as where they live, where
they commute, where they work,
where they have fun.
And by doing several of these
we gather a firm understanding
of people in that context
and their use of technology.
In Station, when we wanted
to build a Wi-Fi service
in train stations of India, we
spent a lot of time hanging out
in train stations.
Talking to passengers,
talking to business owners,
riding trains ourselves
so we could understand
what that experience was like.
And shadowing
passengers who were
embarking on these journeys.
And really what we
wanted to understand
was who is in the station.
What are they doing?
What is the context
of using the Wi-Fi?
What is their
understanding of Wi-Fi?
And these insights led
up to design principles,
such as the service.
The login service to
get onto the network
has to be really efficient
and quick because stations
are high-stress environments,
with a lot of stimulus.
The service has to be
trustworthy and secure.
We saw in our
research that women
were hesitant to give out
phone numbers to log on
to a public Wi-Fi
network, so we really
ensured that the
network was secure.
And that because of the
heterogeneity of devices
in a train station--
this is really the cross-section
of the entire country--
the service was browser-based.
It works as a
captive portal model,
and doesn't require
the installation
of any mobile application.
An example of research
and design techniques
later on in product
development is when
the product is nearing launch.
We've created a technique
called Trusted Testers Studies.
These are large panels of
representative participants
who are recruited
to consensually make
use of the application
and provide feedbacks.
And we collect qualitative
and quantitative data.
We ran several of these
trusted testers studies
for Datally in various
parts of the Philippines,
where we had hundreds of
participants using Datally
for three to four months.
That gave us a really
firm understanding of,
what are the core use cases?
What's the resident
value proposition?
What are issues
that we're running
into that we need
to fix, before we
launch the product in mock-in?
JOSH WOODWARD: That's great.
Cool.
That's it.
Thank you all!
- Thank you.
- Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]